Donald Trump's press secretary Sarah
Huckabee Sanders appeared on Fox Sunday
yesterday and she came out swinging with
whopper after whopper and at some point
in the gong show interview the topic
turned to Donald Trump's tax returns and
just this incredible effort that Donald
Trump and everybody around him have been
making to prevent the release of Donald
Trump's tax returns and Sarah Huckabee
Sanders came up with the idea that
members of the House and Senate simply
aren't smart enough to understand Donald
Trump's tax returns and this is funny
for a few different reasons but let's
first take a look at the clip just so
you know what Chris Wallace is asking
about there's this 1924 law which allows
any member of the House or Senate who is
on tax writing committees to request the
tax returns of individuals that's
exactly what congressman Richard Neal
from Massachusetts did on the basis of
his membership in the House Ways and
Means Committee and that's what Chris
Wallace is asking about here bill the
president demand that the IRS not turn
over as tax returns or will he live this
is I think pretty close to yes or no or
will he live with whatever the IRS
decides and the president's been clear
from the beginning as long as his taxes
are under audit he's not going to
release them he's also filled out
hundreds of pages in financial
disclosures I know but will he tell the
IRS not hold on Chris this isn't well
they tell me how I arrest not to release
them now I want to see what happens on
that front but the president's been
clear this issue has even been litigated
we went through it in 2016 but one of
the biggest things that I think people
aren't seeing is the fact that the only
reason that the Oversight Committee has
the ability to request someone's taxes
or for the purpose of determining policy
this has nothing to do with whether or
not they're going to determine policy
this is all about political partisanship
this is a dangerous dangerous road and
frankly Chris I don't think Congress
particularly not this group of
congressmen and women are smart enough
to look through the thousands of pages
that I would assume that President
Trump's taxes will be my guest says most
of them don't do their own taxes and
certainly don't trust them to look
through the decades of success that the
president has that's right people who
don't do their own taxes are unable to
analyze anyone else's taxes in a
meaningful way and by the way while
we're at it along the same lines anyone
who isn't the pilot isn't able to
analyze what took place during a flight
to tell you whether the flight went okay
or not anybody who's not a professional
racecar driver can't watch the race and
accurately assess how it went and
anybody who's not a teacher is unable to
tell you whether a student is doing well
or not oh wait a second that's idiotic
and it makes no sense she says the
people in Congress don't do their own
taxes so they can't understand Trump's
what does that matter Trump also doesn't
do his own taxes and more importantly
it's interesting that she says the
current members of Congress aren't smart
enough to understand Trump's taxes the
issue really isn't about intelligence
it's do they have the knowledge to
understand Trump's taxes there are lots
of really smart doctors who don't
understand taxes it's not because
they're not smart it's because it's not
their field there's lots of accountants
who are terrible at analyzing chess it's
not because they aren't smart enough
they simply lack the knowledge because
their field as being accountants not
chess this is what makes it a
transparent attack because Sarah
Huckabee Sanders could say personal
taxes aren't their field rather than
they're not smart which by the way there
are ten accountants in the House and
Senate so that's also a hard argument to
make instead she makes it about they
aren't smart people which deliberately
muddies the water and in any case they
can hire experts who know how to look at
taxes of course they can and that makes
this an even more a sort of ignorant and
idiotic assertion but there is one thing
here that I have to say Sarah Huckabee
Sanders may be right about and it
actually might keep Donald Trump's taxes
private which is that there doesn't
appear to be a clear legislative purpose
for looking at Donald Trump's taxes and
what I mean by that is the 1924 law that
Richard Neal is using here to justify
thing Trump's taxes it doesn't say
anything about the president gets to say
yea or nay on the release of his taxes
the president doesn't get to direct the
Attorney General to either authorize or
block the release of the taxes but the
context of this law even existing does
appear to be according to numerous legal
experts for legislative purposes so the
House Ways and Means Committee and
Richard Neal may ultimately have to
defend the request with some kind of
explanation as to what their legislative
imperative is what is it that they're
looking to do legislatively on the basis
of obtaining Donald Trump's taxes
Sanders as usual stunningly dishonest
disgustingly ignorant but there is a
grain of truth in what she said and that
ultimately may actually keep Donald
Trump's tax returns away from the House
Ways and Means Committee we'll just have
to wait and see